Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. In the year 1066 occurred the other memorable date in English history, viz. William the Conqueror 1066. This is also called the Battle of Hastings. When William the Conqueror landed, he lay down on the beach and swallowed two mouthfuls of sand. This was his first conquering action and was in the south. Later he ravaged the north as well. The Norman conquest was a good thing as from this time onwards England stopped being conquered and thus was able to become top nation. So says W.C. Seller and R.G.
感谢收听《历史的余味》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。1066年发生了英国历史上另一个值得纪念的日期，即威廉征服者1066年。这也称为黑斯廷斯战役。当威廉征服者登陆时，他躺在沙滩上，吞了两口沙子。这是他在南方的第一次征服行动。后来他也蹂躏了北方。诺曼征服是一件好事，因为从那时起，英国不再被征服，从而能够成为顶级国家。W.C. 塞勒和 R.G. 耶特曼的经典著作《1066及所有那一切》如是说，我有什么资格反驳呢？欢迎收看《历史的余味》，我是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，盎格鲁-撒克逊人的浪漫、热爱自由的继承人，以及灰暗、冷酷的汤姆·霍兰德，一个彻头彻尾的诺曼人。谢谢多米尼克的介绍。你知道吗，我实际上在国家电视台上扮演过威廉征服者？你当然扮演过。是的，所以我是一个圆滑、邪恶的诺曼人，有着刮得干干净净的下巴。所以当人们把你误认为演员汤姆·霍兰德时，
Yateman's classic 1066 and all that and who am I to disagree? Welcome to The Rest Is History with me Dominic Sandbrook, romantic, freedom-loving heir of the Anglo-Saxons and grey, grim Tom Holland and Norman to his fingertips. Thanks, Dominic, for that introduction. Do you know I have actually played William the Conqueror on national TV? Of course you have. Yes, so I am a sleek, evil Norman to my clean-shaven chops. So when people mistake you for actor Tom Holland,
（接上文）
I mean, you are actor Tom Holland, right? Yes, I am an actor. I mean, he's the impersonator. Well, I think that anyone who saw my performance as William of Normandy would accept that it was a magnificent, thespian performance. Yes, his casting by Marvel was just a colossal case of mistaken identity, right? I mean, they seem you as William the Conqueror. Pretty much.
我的意思是，你是演员汤姆·霍兰德，对吧？是的，我是一名演员。我的意思是，他是那个模仿者。好吧，我认为任何看过我扮演诺曼底威廉的人都会承认，那是一场精彩绝伦的戏剧表演。是的，他被漫威选中只是一个巨大的身份认同错误，对吧？我的意思是，他们把你当成了威廉征服者。差不多吧。
It's taken a time to get on to the Spider-Man jokes, but we finally, well, after 45 episodes, we got on to them. So well done on your restraint. Herculean self-restraint on my part. Yeah, it's been heroic. So, Tom, when I was at school, like you, like probably a lot of our listeners, I learned that there was one date that you had to know in english history it's the defining date in all english history 1066 now do you think that it
花了一段时间才讲到蜘蛛侠的笑话，但我们终于，好吧，在45集之后，我们讲到了。所以你的克制力做得很好。我个人的海格力斯式的自我克制。是的，这真是英雄般的。那么，汤姆，当我在学校时，像你一样，可能像我们许多听众一样，我学到英国历史上有一个日期是你必须知道的，它是整个英国历史上决定性的日期，1066年。现在你认为它
deserves its place first of all well we have a question on that don't we from richard deval who asks is 1066 a genuine pivot point in english history um and i think so give us a sense of what happened i suppose okay so before we come to that before we come to that essentially i think it is because it's um it's a kind of great scorch mark across the line of medieval english history and on the one side you have the period that we call maybe controversially the anglo-saxon period and then we have the period from which we start dating our kings and queens so there were lots of you know there were at least two Edwards who ruled as king of England before the Norman conquest but we start counting Edwards from the 13th century um and that's just a kind of
首先值得拥有这个地位吗？好吧，我们有一个关于这个问题的问题，不是吗？来自理查德·德瓦尔，他问1066年是英国历史上的一个真正转折点吗？嗯，我认为是的。给我们讲讲发生了什么，我想。好吧，在我们谈到那个之前，在我们谈到那个之前，本质上我认为是的，因为它是一个，嗯，它在英国中世纪历史的线上留下了一道巨大的烧焦痕迹。在一边，你有我们可能称之为有争议的盎格鲁-撒克逊时期，然后我们有我们开始记录国王和王后日期的时期。所以有很多，你知道，在诺曼征服之前至少有两个爱德华统治过英格兰，但我们从13世纪开始计算爱德华，嗯，这只是一种
a single indicator of the way in which essentially thean conquest serves to completely reorient everything and i think it's 1066 matters and and is indeed decisive because over the course of the millennium since people have seen it as such and so have kind of yeah you know constructed entire mythologies around it the idea very popular in the 17th century of the norman yoke um the idea that england has never been invaded since which of course isn't true but it establishes an idea of england as freedom loving that has incredible influence through the 19th and 20th century so i think it matters for those reasons um but it's also i i think it matters in the context of the um 11th century because essentially what the Normans represent is this kind of revolutionary movement which is escalating on the continent at the same time as the Norman invasion
一个单一的指标，表明诺曼征服本质上是如何彻底重塑一切的。我认为1066年很重要，而且确实是决定性的，因为在过去的一千年里，人们一直这样看待它，所以也以某种方式围绕它构建了整个神话。17世纪非常流行的“诺曼枷锁”观念，即英国自那以后从未被入侵过的观念，当然这不是真的，但它确立了一个英国热爱自由的观念，这在19世纪和20世纪产生了不可思议的影响。所以我认为它因为这些原因很重要，嗯，但我也认为它在11世纪的背景下很重要，因为本质上诺曼人代表的是一种革命运动，它在诺曼入侵的同时在欧洲大陆升级。
and it's both a military revolution and a religious revolution and the Norman conquest is very much a part of that story so we might get onto that later on um i would never have believed you would have found a way to fit religion but religious revolutions into the story of 1066 but this is fantastic work tom this is the 11th century it is the 11th century is the is the it's not just very religious this is the great seismic you know this is the moment of revolution the the the papal revolution that transforms the medieval world there's no century that you don't say that of though the 11th century i've always said is is the revolutionary century and i think it makes sense to put see 1066 in that kind of broader perspective let me try and put you back
这既是一场军事革命，也是一场宗教革命，诺曼征服在很大程度上是那个故事的一部分。所以我们以后可能会谈到这一点。我永远不会相信你会找到一种方法把宗教，但宗教革命融入到1066年的故事中，但这真是太棒了，汤姆。这是11世纪，这是11世纪，不仅仅是非常宗教，这是伟大的地震，你知道，这是革命的时刻，改变中世纪世界的教皇革命。虽然没有哪个世纪你不会这么说，但我一直说11世纪是革命的世纪，我认为把1066年放在那种更广阔的视角下是有意义的。让我试着把你拉回来
on your on your leash um tell us what happened in 1066 in about 10 sentences okay i'll try yeah sweep if that's if that's doable there's a reason why um students when they go to secondary school study it in year seven because it's a very inherently dramatic story and basically it's a kind of three-way game of thrones you've got um harold godwinson son of an overmighty earl uh you have harold hardrada harold the hard ruler the king of norway and you have william the duke of normandy um the most kind of terrifyingly able man in france all of whom essentially have their eyes on the crown of England. And the crown of England becomes available on the 5th of January 1066, when the previous king, Edward the Confessor, dies childless. And so there is this massive scramble. Harold Godwinson has himself crowned
在你的，在你的束缚下，告诉我1066年发生了什么，用大约10句话。好吧，我会试一试。是的，如果可行的话。学生们上中学时在七年级学习它是有原因的，因为它本质上是一个非常戏剧性的故事。基本上，这是一场三方权力的游戏。你有哈罗德·戈德温森，一位权势过大的伯爵的儿子；你有哈罗德·哈德拉达，哈罗德硬统治者，挪威国王；还有威廉，诺曼底公爵，法国最令人恐惧的有能力的人。他们本质上都盯着英格兰的王冠。而英格兰的王冠在1066年1月5日，当上一任国王忏悔者爱德华无嗣而终时变得空缺。所以发生了一场巨大的争夺。哈罗德·戈德温森让自己加冕
very rapidly in the newly built abbey at Westminster. This provokes William to fury because William thinks that both Edward the Confessor and Harold are committed to him succeeding to the throne. Meanwhile Harold Godwinson's brother Tostig has had a massive bust up, has left England in a half, has gone off to Norway where he's talked to Harold Hardrada, a terrifying Viking of the old school, persuaded him that he could come over and grab the throne. So over the course of 1066, you have these three men all competing for the throne. It's in the shadow of Halley's Comet, a sure portent of doom and disaster.
非常迅速地在新建的威斯敏斯特教堂。这激怒了威廉，因为威廉认为忏悔者爱德华和哈罗德都承诺让他继承王位。与此同时，哈罗德·戈德温森的兄弟托斯蒂格发生了一场巨大的争吵，匆忙离开了英格兰，去了挪威，在那里他与哈罗德·哈德拉达谈过，一个老派的可怕维京人，说服他可以过来夺取王位。所以在1066年期间，你有这三个人都在争夺王位。它在哈雷彗星的阴影下，这是厄运和灾难的确定预兆。
Harold Godwinson is stationed on the south coast of England waiting for the Normans to invade. Contrary winds stop William from crossing the channel. While he's down there, he's brought the news that Harold Hardrada and Tostig have invaded, have sailed up the Humber, have defeated the earls of Northumbria and Mercia, have seized York. Harold Godmanson marches at a furious speed, takes Tostig and Harold Hardrada by surprise, defeats them at the Battle of Stamford Bridge. He's just breathing a deep sigh of relief when he's informed that the Normans have landed on the south coast. So he hares back down there meets them at um a hill uh some seven miles north of hastings um a battle is fought all day harold ends up dead william um ends up uh waits for the anglo-saxon nobility to um accept him they don't so he starts to ravage the south this is sufficiently effective that
哈罗德·戈德温森驻扎在英格兰南海岸，等待诺曼人入侵。逆风阻止了威廉穿越海峡。当他在那里时，他带来了哈罗德·哈德拉达和托斯蒂格已经入侵的消息，他们沿亨伯河航行，击败了诺森布里亚和麦西亚的伯爵，占领了约克。哈罗德·戈德温森以极快的速度行军，出其不意地抓住了托斯蒂格和哈罗德·哈德拉达，在斯坦福桥战役中击败了他们。他刚松了一口气，就被告知诺曼人已经在南海岸登陆。所以他匆忙赶回那里，在黑斯廷斯以北约七英里的山上遇到了他们。战斗打了一整天，哈罗德最终死了。威廉最终等待盎格鲁-撒克逊贵族接受他，他们没有，所以他开始蹂躏南方。这非常有效，以至于
on Christmas day 1066 he is able to have taken possession of London and on that day he is crowned in Westminster Abbey as king of England so it's an incredibly dramatic story and I'm sure again part of the reason why it has this seismic role in English history is simply that it's so dramatic and in lots of ways unusual. It's a great story. Well done, Tom. That was a bravura performance. And it is a kind of Game of Thrones, isn't it? But what's interesting to me about it, just thinking about it
在1066年圣诞节，他已经能够占领伦敦，并在那天他在威斯敏斯特教堂加冕为英格兰国王。所以这是一个令人难以置信的戏剧性故事，我相信这也是它在英国历史中具有这种地震般作用的部分原因，仅仅是因为它太戏剧性了，而且在很多方面都很不寻常。这是一个伟大的故事。做得好，汤姆。那是一场精彩的表演。这确实是一种权力的游戏，不是吗？但对我来说有趣的是，在录音前思考它，
before we're recording, is that in the popular imagination, there's this sort of period of bucolic Anglo-Saxon peace and then these bastards arrive from Normandy and burn everything and smash everything up and the norman conquest is this great traumatic rupture but the interesting thing is that england i mean it is very rich england is very you know it has a very sort of potent state
是在大众想象中，有一段田园诗般的盎格鲁-撒克逊和平时期，然后这些混蛋从诺曼底赶来，烧毁一切，砸碎一切，诺曼征服是这种巨大的创伤性断裂。但有趣的是，英格兰，我的意思是它非常富有，英格兰非常，你知道，它有一种非常强大的国家，
so it's very good at raising taxes and it has the sort of shires and all the rest of it but england is has kind of been up for grabs for a while so england has been invaded by the danes it's been run by canute it's been part of a north sea empire and the normans the norman influence has been getting stronger in england for decades hasn't it before the norman conquest so edward the confessor is half norman he's got norman friends he's given lands to some normans in a way yeah and harold godwinson is half scandinavian so exactly so isn't this basically england is going to be taken over by one of these two sort of powers either norway or normandy both but viking powers basically and it's inevitable do you not
所以它非常擅长征税，它有郡之类的东西，但英格兰有一段时间一直处于被争夺的状态。所以英格兰被丹麦人入侵过，被克努特统治过，它是北海帝国的一部分，而诺曼人的影响在诺曼征服前几十年就已经在英格兰变得越来越强了，不是吗？所以忏悔者爱德华是半个诺曼人，他有诺曼朋友，他在某种程度上给了诺曼人一些土地。是的，哈罗德·戈德温森是半个斯堪的纳维亚人。所以完全正确，所以这基本上不是英格兰将被这两个权力之一接管吗？要么是挪威，要么是诺曼底，基本上都是维京人的权力，这是不可避免的，你不
think do you think this place it's going to be dragged into the orbit either of scandinavia or of normandy and france and the only question is which i think it was always going to be that of france i think it was always going to be because of this the the scale of this ongoing kind of revolutionary ferment in france but you're right okay that it is also um i mean essentially england is is too rich and too successful i mean it sounds an old thing to say but the the unitary kingdom of england that gets founded in in the 10th century is incredibly precocious by the standards of the rest of europe where where this kind of centralized nation state doesn't really exist you mustn't
认为吗？你认为这个地方会被拖入斯堪的纳维亚或诺曼底和法国的轨道，唯一的问题是哪一个。我认为它总是会是法国的，我认为它总是会是，因为这种在法国持续不断的革命性发酵的规模。但你是对的，好吧，它也是，嗯，我的意思是本质上英格兰太富有、太成功了。我的意思是，说这话听起来很老套，但在10世纪建立的英格兰统一王国，按照欧洲其他地区的标准来看，是非常早熟的，那种集权民族国家并不真正存在。你绝不能
overemphasize the centralization i mean the north is is is very roughly controlled but it is there that there are recognized boundaries there's a single faith there's almost a kind of single language i mean the dialects are kind of pretty much mutually intelligible there's a single religion there's a single king and that there are these kind of incredible abilities to raise taxes so it's it's by the standards of other lands very very wealthy but that's a problem because you're surrounded by robbers so it's kind of like walking through um you know a a place where there are lots of muggings with um wearing a kind of you know wearing diamonds or something i mean it's kind of asking for trouble um and the v of, you know, wearing diamonds or something. I mean, it's kind of asking for trouble. And the Vikings, you know, this is incredibly appealing to them, of course.
过分强调集权。我的意思是，北方受到的控制非常粗糙，但它确实存在，有公认的边界，有单一的信仰，几乎有一种单一的语言。我的意思是，方言基本上是可以互通的，有单一的宗教，有单一的国王，而且有这种征税的不可思议的能力。所以按照其他土地的标准，它非常非常富有，但这是个问题，因为你被强盗包围了。所以这有点像走过，嗯，你知道，一个有很多抢劫的地方，戴着，你知道，戴着钻石之类的东西。我的意思是，这有点自找麻烦。而维京人，你知道，这对他们来说非常有吸引力，当然。
So they come over and it's in the reign of Æthelred the Unready. Canute establishes his reign. Absolutely. Essentially, Harold Ardrada in that sense is kind of old school because what he's doing, you know, Vikings have been doing pretty much since the the rain on linda the raid on linda's farm um is basically kind of come in and grab stuff um william i think is is different because he he although harold harold hardrada is christian and indeed is is the half brother of the man who will become um norway's patron saint say do laugh he's he's christian in the sense that everyone has to be christian
所以他们过来了，那是在埃塞尔雷德无准备者统治时期。克努特建立了他的统治。绝对的。本质上，哈罗德·哈德拉达在那种意义上是老派的，因为他在做什么，你知道，维京人基本上从林迪斯法恩的袭击以来一直在做，基本上就是进来抢东西。威廉，我认为是不同的，因为他，虽然哈罗德·哈德拉达是基督徒，而且确实是未来挪威守护神圣奥拉夫的同父异母兄弟，他是基督徒，在每个人都必须是基督徒的意义上，
so he doesn't believe it i don't think he's not a turning the other cheek man he's very much not a turn the other cheek man for william it's it's different because William really passionately believes that God wants him to have the throne and that Edward the Confessor, I think, and I think he's right to do this. famous episode that appears on the bay tapestry um a year or so before 1066 has been shipwrecked um and essentially rescued by william from captivity uh and he has sworn an oath um on the bones of saints that he will back william's um right to the throne and william's that a story just told by propagandists I don't think so true is that I think it's you think it's real yeah I think it is because I don't think Harold would have got away otherwise I mean the the debate is over why Harold has gone there so the English sources say that it's to to ransom some captives that some hostages that William has
所以他不相信它，我不认为他不是一个转过脸去的人。他绝对不是一个转过脸去的人。对于威廉来说，这是不同的，因为威廉真的热切地相信上帝希望他拥有王位，而且忏悔者爱德华，我认为，而且我认为他这样做是对的。贝叶挂毯上出现的著名插曲，在1066年前一年左右，曾遭遇海难，本质上被威廉从囚禁中救出，他发誓，在圣徒的骨头上，他将支持威廉的王位权利。威廉的那个故事只是宣传家讲的吗？我不这么认为，是真的吗？我认为它是，你认为它是真的？是的，我认为它是，因为我不认为哈罗德否则能逃脱。我的意思是，争论在于哈罗德为什么去那里。所以英国的消息来源说那是为了赎回一些俘虏，一些威廉扣押的人质，
and the the Normans say that he's been sent there by Edward the Confessor I think the English sources there are probably truer but I think it's pretty clear that Harold did do it and the Normans say that he's been sent there by Edward the Confessor. I think the English sources there are probably truer, but I think it's pretty clear that Harold did do it. And the reason that Harold does this is because he doesn't take it seriously. So there's a fabulous description of him in one of the, in the life of Edward the Confessor, written a decade or so after 1066, where it refers to his his watchful mockery that he takes from ambush to ambush and i think there's the sense that he feels it doesn't really
而诺曼人说他是被忏悔者爱德华派到那里的。我认为英国的消息来源可能更真实，但我认为很清楚哈罗德确实做了这件事。而诺曼人说他是被忏悔者爱德华派到那里的。我认为英国的消息来源可能更真实，但我认为很清楚哈罗德确实做了这件事。哈罗德这样做的原因是，他没有认真对待它。所以有一段关于他的精彩描述，在1066年后十年左右写的《忏悔者爱德华传》中，它提到了他那种“警惕的嘲弄”，他从伏击到伏击，我认为有一种感觉，他觉得这并不真正
matter and i think more than that that his he's in normandy he's able to scope out william and and exactly calculate what he is up against um but the problem for har is that William is signed up to the idea that essentially if he is going to England, he will be doing so as the agent of God. And as proof of that... So he's got a papal banner or something? He has a papal banner, which is very shocking because it's none of the business of the papacy to intervene in this kind of thing this is this is a period where um the reach of the papacy is nothing like what it becomes even within a decade or so because this is the period where reformers in rome are starting to use the papacy as a way to bring the whole of christendom to heal as they see it to subjective to a process of reformatio. And England is a massive prize. England is a kind of
重要。而且我认为更重要的是，他在诺曼底，他能够观察威廉，并准确计算出他所面对的是什么。但哈罗德的问题是，威廉签署了这样一个想法，即本质上如果他要去英格兰，他将作为上帝的代理人这样做。作为证明……所以他有一个教皇旗帜之类的东西？他有一个教皇旗帜，这非常令人震惊，因为教皇干预这种事情是不关他的事的。这是一个时期，嗯，教皇的影响力远不及十年左右后的样子，因为这是罗马的改革者开始利用教皇作为一种方式，按照他们的看法，让整个基督教世界服从，使之服从于一种“改革”的过程。而英格兰是一个巨大的奖品。英格兰是一种
ancient Christian country, but the Archbishop of Canterbury, a guy called Stigand, is absolutely representative of everything that the reformers in Rome dislike. He's corrupt, he holds multiple benefits, he does not take his faith seriously at all. so the chance to bring england to heel is hugely hugely tempting and the guy um behind the um the pope who who essentially persuades the pope alexander ii to give a banner with a papal blessing to william is a guy called hildebrand who in due course will become pope gregory vii and g. And Gregory VII is the great revolutionary pope of the 11th century. And he's the guy who at Canossa Castle in the north of the Apennines will get Henry IV, the emperor himself, to kneel in the snow and humble himself. And essentially,
古老的基督教国家，但坎特伯雷大主教，一个叫斯蒂甘德的人，绝对代表了罗马改革者所不喜欢的一切。他腐败，他拥有多个圣职，他根本不认真对待他的信仰。所以让英格兰服从的机会是非常非常有诱惑力的。而那个在教皇背后，本质上说服教皇亚历山大二世给威廉一面带有教皇祝福的旗帜的人，是一个叫希尔德布兰德的人，他最终将成为教皇格列高利七世。而格列高利七世是11世纪伟大的革命教皇。他就是在亚平宁山脉北部的卡诺萨城堡，让皇帝亨利四世跪在雪地里谦卑自己的人。本质上，
the humbling of Harold is a part of this. And people who are opposed to what Gregory VII are doing, opposed to what the reformers are doing, opposed to this policy of essentially kind of shaking Christendom up, cleansing it, purifying it, making it more truly Christian. They compare Gregory VII Hildebrand's approach to Henry IV and they cast it as kind of rebellion as as upstart behavior as revolutionary behavior and they explicitly compare it to um what William had done to Harold you know the the murder and dismemberment of a Christian king yeah so I think that that that is a massive massive part of the context for it and that's why when after the battle of hastings william builds a great abbey on the site where harold fell and the high the high altar yeah battle abbey so battle abbey the high altar is supposed to stand on the spot where harold fell and this is a gesture of penance that that for william is a truly heartfelt one and everyone all the normans who fought at
哈罗德的谦卑是其中的一部分。而那些反对格列高利七世所做之事的人，反对改革者所做之事的人，反对这种本质上动摇基督教世界、净化它、纯洁它、使它更真正基督教化的政策的人，他们将格列高利七世希尔德布兰德对亨利四世的方法进行了比较，并将它描述为一种叛乱，一种暴发户行为，一种革命行为，他们明确地将其与威廉对哈罗德所做的事情进行了比较，你知道，谋杀和肢解一位基督教国王。是的，所以我认为那是它的一个巨大巨大的背景，这就是为什么在黑斯廷斯战役后，威廉在哈罗德倒下的地方建造了一座伟大的修道院，高祭坛，是的，战斗修道院。所以战斗修道院的高祭坛应该站在哈罗德倒下的地方，这是一种忏悔的姿态，对威廉来说，这是一个真正衷心的姿态，所有在
hastings have to do penance for the death that they inflicted so there is a kind of normans are kind of they're more christian they're more they're or that they wear their christianity more heavily than harold and his and the godwinsons and their sort of hangers-on and henchmen. Is that fair? I think so. They are militant in their Christianity in a terrifying way. And a sort of allied question. So lots of novelists, I think of Julian Rathbone wrote a book on this called The Last English King. Lots of novelists have written about this.
黑斯廷斯战斗的诺曼人都必须为他们造成的死亡进行忏悔。所以有一种诺曼人，他们更基督教，他们更，或者说他们比哈罗德和他的戈德温森家族以及他们的追随者和党羽更沉重地承担他们的基督教信仰。这公平吗？我认为是的。他们在基督教信仰上是好战的，以一种可怕的方式。还有一个相关的问题。所以很多小说家，我想到了朱利安·拉斯伯恩写了一本关于这个的书，叫《最后的英国国王》。很多小说家都写过这个。
And of course, it's the stuff of children's history books. And we always attempted to project personalities onto these characters so we're going to come to Harold Hardrada later because there's lots of questions about him. He's this amazing character. Harold Godwinson for lots of people is this kind of romantic hero who falls in battle basically
当然，这是儿童历史书的内容。我们总是试图将个性投射到这些角色身上，所以我们稍后会谈到哈罗德·哈德拉达，因为有很多关于他的问题。他是一个了不起的角色。对很多人来说，哈罗德·戈德温森是一个浪漫的英雄，他在战斗中倒下，基本上
after a massive fixture pile up. And William is kind of a new Satan. So you know yourself. So he's kind of this grim, very political, you know, very intense, supremely competent, terrifying figure. How much of that do you think is us projecting personalities, sort of Hollywood style, onto these people who are basically, I mean,
在一场巨大的冲突之后。而威廉是一种新的撒旦。所以你自己也知道。所以他是一种冷酷的、非常政治的、你知道，非常强烈的、极其能干的、可怕的人物。你认为其中有多少是我们投射个性，好莱坞风格，到这些人身上，他们基本上，我的意思是，
they're basically competing warlords, right? They're leaders of gangs. They're pretty scary people who now we would think of as kind of the equivalent of you know vladimir putin and and sort of that's they're tough guys and are our modern impressions of them basically romantic inventions do you think but they've been mythologized right from the right from the right from the right from the beginning so the image so the story that this you know harold hardrada is the hero of icelandic saga so there's all this stuff about how he he goes off to byzantium how he fights dragons how he has affairs with empresses how he conquers the holy land i mean it's all totally obviously
他们基本上是竞争的军阀，对吧？他们是帮派的头目。他们是相当可怕的人，现在我们会认为他们相当于，你知道，弗拉基米尔·普京，那种，他们是硬汉，你认为我们对他们的现代印象基本上是浪漫的发明吗？但他们从一开始就被神话了。所以形象，所以故事，这个，你知道，哈罗德·哈德拉达是冰岛萨迦的英雄，所以有所有关于他如何去拜占庭，如何与龙战斗，如何与皇后有染，如何征服圣地的东西，我的意思是，这一切完全显然是
totally made up um and it it draws on the fact that Harold Hardrada, as a young man, did go to Constantinople, did clearly cut a tremendous dash with the Varangian Guard, came back with lots of cash, made himself, you know, with which he was able to win war bands and win the crown of Norway. I mean, clearly he's, as my brother would say, a massive lad. Like Neville Chamberlain. Yeah, like Neville Chamberlain. He's a terrifying, I mean, of course he's a's he's as my brother would say a massive lad like neville chamberlain yeah i never tell you he's a terrifying i mean of course he's a terrifying guy and that's why people write epics about him harold godwinson likewise is i mean this is a guy who's fighting the welsh um and gets given the head of the welsh prince who he's been fighting and treats it as a trophy. Yeah.
完全编造的。嗯，它利用了哈罗德·哈德拉达年轻时确实去过君士坦丁堡，确实在瓦兰吉卫队中表现出色，带着大量现金回来，使自己，你知道，用这些现金他能够赢得战争乐队并赢得挪威王冠的事实。我的意思是，显然他，正如我兄弟所说，是一个巨大的家伙。像内维尔·张伯伦。是的，像内维尔·张伯伦。他是一个可怕的，我的意思是，当然他是一个可怕的家伙，这就是为什么人们写关于他的史诗。哈罗德·戈德温森同样，我的意思是，这是一个正在与威尔士人战斗的家伙，并得到了他一直在战斗的威尔士王子的头颅，并将其视为战利品。是的。
Now, to the Normans. He's kind of listening to poetry and holding hands with Edith, his wife. Edith Swanneck. Yes. Yeah. And he's loving kind of Anglo-Saxon traditions and all that. That's all balls, is it? I think, I mean, I think he's, Harold, Harold Gormson is a charismatic man.
现在，对诺曼人来说。他有点在听诗歌，和他的妻子伊迪丝手牵手。伊迪丝·斯旺内克。是的。是的。他热爱盎格鲁-撒克逊传统和所有这些。那全是胡扯，是吗？我认为，我的意思是，我认为他是，哈罗德，哈罗德·戈德温森是一个有魅力的人。
He must have been to win the support uh essentially he i mean he you see harold goddinson is um he's a kind of uh a decent richard iii he's a usurper like richard iii there is you know there is an atheling a man yeah a prince who should become king in the form of edgar edgar is the um the the grandson of edmund ironside the english king who fought canute and then and then died um edmund ironside's son had been brought up in hungary he'd come back to england he died almost immediately edgar is the son he's only about 13 in 1066 so he's not really able to to have the crown but even so um he's the rightful heir harold godwin yeah harold godwin elbows him out the way i mean but doesn't kill him or anything so so so he's a nice richard the third but but he's so he's a charismatic man to persuade all the other noblemen to to sign up to that but yeah a usurper is only a usurper is only remembered as a usurper if they
他一定是为了赢得支持，本质上他，我的意思是，你看哈罗德·戈德温森是，嗯，他是一个体面的理查三世，他是一个像理查三世一样的篡位者。有，你知道，有一个王位继承人，一个男人，是的，一个王子，他应该成为国王，以埃德加的形式。埃德加是埃德蒙·铁边，那个与克努特战斗然后死去的英国国王的孙子。埃德蒙·铁边的儿子在匈牙利长大，他回到英格兰，几乎立即就死了。埃德加是他的儿子，他在1066年只有13岁左右，所以他真的没有能力拥有王冠，但即便如此，他是合法的继承人。哈罗德·戈德温，是的，哈罗德·戈德温把他挤到了一边。我的意思是，但没有杀他或什么的。所以，所以他是一个好理查三世，但他是一个有魅力的人，能说服所有其他贵族签署这个协议。但是的，篡位者只有在
then lose aren't they if they're a usurper and they win then they're just part of the canon so no one thinks of them as also and also it's more confused because um the the laws around who becomes king is you know it's it's more up for grabs essentially it's an elective office and you then get it sealed with a coronation um so uh harold you know i mean he's elected king um so he he clearly is charismatic and i think you you get the sense from that thing of him, you know, the watchful mockery. I think that that's written within his lifetime. And I think that that's clearly true to the style that he brings to kingship. He's he's an amusing, amused kind of man.
然后失败时才会被记住为篡位者，不是吗？如果他们是篡位者并且他们赢了，那么他们只是经典的一部分。所以没有人认为他们也是。而且更混乱，因为，嗯，关于谁成为国王的法律，你知道，它更处于被争夺的状态。本质上，这是一个选举产生的职位，然后你用加冕礼来密封它。所以，哈罗德，你知道，我的意思是，他被选为国王，所以他显然很有魅力，而且我认为你从他那种，你知道，警惕的嘲弄中得到了感觉。我认为那是他有生之年写的。而且我认为这显然符合他带给王权的风格。他是一个有趣的、被逗乐的人。
William, you know, I mean, he he's he's terrifying because he's terrifyingly able and he's terrifying in the way that um very very competent revolutionaries are invariably terrifying and the thing is that that the revolution is not just religious it's also military because um this in France this is the age of two very, very significant developments. One of which is the realization, particularly in Anjou, who William fights against for decades before he launches his attack on England. The Angevins recognize that you can use castles as tools of oppression. Yes. So they start.
威廉，你知道，我的意思是，他很可怕，因为他极其能干，而且他很可怕，以一种，嗯，非常非常能干的革命者总是很可怕的方式。而且事情是，那场革命不仅是宗教的，也是军事的，因为，嗯，在法国，这是两个非常非常重要的发展的时代。其中之一是认识到，特别是在安茹，威廉在发动对英格兰的攻击前与他们战斗了几十年。安茹人认识到你可以利用城堡作为压迫工具。是的。所以他们开始。
There's no word in english for castles is there when the normans come over no people don't know what they are no they've got no idea whereas all along the you know the loire the early chateau are going up and essentially um the uh the angevin counts are able to use these chateaus as ways of establishing themselves as kind of power you know they come from almost nowhere to become the major power in central france and the normans pick up on this very very quickly the scope for castles and william as a as a boy you know he's he he becomes duke very very young so he has to put up with all the noblemen's whacking castles up all over the place and he spends his early years essentially breaking that power so he's very very alert to
英语中没有城堡这个词，对吧，当诺曼人过来时？没有，人们不知道它们是什么。没有，他们根本不知道。而一直以来，卢瓦尔河沿岸，早期的城堡正在兴起，本质上，嗯，安茹伯爵能够利用这些城堡作为建立自己的一种权力的方式，你知道，他们几乎从无到有，成为法国中部的强大力量。而诺曼人非常非常快地意识到了这一点，城堡的范围，威廉作为一个男孩，你知道，他非常非常年轻就成为了公爵，所以他不得不忍受所有贵族在各地建造城堡，他早年基本上是在打破那种权力。所以他非常非常警惕
the use that castles play and he's able to do that because he is a norman and the normans are kind of proficient at the other great development which is the um the use of horses as a tool of oppression so you've got castles and horses and these are of course knights knights yes yeah yes and i mean essentially to to be in the neighborhood with the normans is like being stuck in a bottle with a hornet these are these are terrifying in the way that the spartans were terrifying or the romans of the of the mid-republic were terrifying these are people who are completely organized for war who live and breathe it will William has been in the saddle training for war since he was a boy.
城堡所起的作用，他能够做到这一点，因为他是诺曼人，而诺曼人擅长另一个伟大的发展，即，嗯，利用马匹作为压迫工具。所以你有城堡和马匹，这些当然是骑士，骑士，是的，是的。我的意思是，本质上，和诺曼人做邻居就像被困在一个装有大黄蜂的瓶子里。这些，这些在斯巴达人可怕或罗马共和国中期的罗马人可怕的方式上是可怕的。这些人是完全为战争组织的，他们生活并呼吸着它。威廉从男孩时代起就一直在马鞍上为战争训练。
And the Anglo-Saxons, although they fight a lot, are not organised for war in that way. And they do not have castles. They have kind of wooden halls that are unprotected. So that is what enables the Norman conquest to work, is that they are introducing this terrifying military technology, which is transforming France and which England is very, very vulnerable to.
而盎格鲁-撒克逊人，虽然他们经常打仗，但并没有以那种方式为战争组织起来。而且他们没有城堡。他们有那种没有保护的木制大厅。所以这就是使诺曼征服能够成功的原因，因为他们引入了这种可怕的军事技术，这正在改变法国，而英格兰对此非常非常脆弱。
So, Tom, we're going to have to take a break in a second and then do the questions. But before we do that, I want to ask you what you think about this. So England has become quite a potent unitary state, the most united, the most sophisticated governing apparatus really in Europe. And some people say the first European nation state, partly under threat from Viking invasions. So because of the
所以，汤姆，我们马上要休息一下，然后做问题。但在我们做之前，我想问你对此有什么看法。所以英格兰已经成为一个相当强大的统一国家，实际上是欧洲最统一、最复杂的治理机构。有些人说是第一个欧洲民族国家，部分是在维京入侵的威胁下。所以因为
Viking invasions, because the constant need to raise money to fight them off and to sort the defences out and stuff, English kings before 1066 have built, have created with their thanes and whatnot, this great state that makes it a prize. So you can decapitate the king and you can take it over and then you'll be very rich.
维京入侵，因为不断需要筹集资金来击退他们并整理防御工事之类的东西，1066年前的英国国王们与他们的领主们等等，建立了这个伟大的国家，使它成为一个奖品。所以你可以斩首国王，你可以接管它，然后你就会非常富有。
So the question is, why haven't they created a technological military apparatus to go along with that? So in other words, why are they behind? If they are ahead of other european sort of states in tax raising and all that stuff why are they behind technologically in military terms is it because they to do with the geography is it because they're only having to fight vikings what's the reason it's it's precisely because the english state is as unitary as it is, that the king, or at least the, you know, the earls who rule the former kingdoms of Wessex and Mercia and East Anglia and Northumbria have sufficient authority that people who give them any shit can, you know, will come to a
所以问题是，为什么他们没有创造一种技术性的军事机构来配合这一点？所以换句话说，为什么他们落后了？如果他们在征税等方面领先于其他欧洲国家，为什么他们在军事上落后了？是因为他们与地理有关吗？是因为他们只需要与维京人作战吗？原因是什么？这正是因为英国国家是统一的，国王，或者至少是，你知道，统治威塞克斯、麦西亚、东盎格利亚和诺森布里亚前王国的伯爵们有足够的权威，以至于给他们任何麻烦的人，你知道，会有一个
grisly end. That is not what happens in France. In France, the power of the king shrivels and shrivels and shrivels until essentially it's just focused on the yield of paris um and that means that all that the duchies and are essentially kind of fair game for anyone who wants to grab it so you have a state of kind of organized anarchy across what will become the kingdom of france and this is a breeding ground for um for for oppression so it's it's kind of like you know um you know one city where you have mob rule you have the mafia uh you know the mafia become incredibly good at extorting stuff and then they muscle into a city where there's no mafia at all and suddenly all the shopkeepers are having to you know they have no protection against it and that's that essentially is the situation that there's no need for castles or knights
可怕的结局。在法国，情况并非如此。在法国，国王的权力萎缩、萎缩、再萎缩，直到本质上它只集中在巴黎的收益上，这意味着所有的公国本质上都是任何想抢夺它的人的公平游戏。所以你在未来将成为法国王国的土地上有一种有组织的无政府状态，这是压迫的温床。所以它有点像，你知道，嗯，你知道，一个有暴民统治的城市，你有黑手党，你知道，黑手党在勒索东西方面变得非常擅长，然后他们挤进一个根本没有黑手党的城市，突然所有的店主都不得不，你知道，他们对此没有任何保护。而这本质上就是这种情况，没有必要建造城堡或骑士
in england because you have the the unitary monarchy but that's precisely what makes it as so vulnerable in a weird way competition the sort of anarchic competition of life in france breeds innovation and success basically britain is almost a victim of its own well it's a it's a victim of a different kind of success yeah and and this this kind of potent new form of of I mean it is oppression with the knights and the castles it's not just England that and and in the due course Scotland andland that suffers from it it's also um in italy so norman adventurers travel there they conquer southern italy they conquer um the muslim uh state in in sicily they invade the balkans they um you know they they give the byzantine emperor
在英格兰，因为你有统一的君主制，但这正是以一种奇怪的方式使它如此脆弱的原因。竞争，法国生活的无政府竞争基本上孕育了创新和成功。英国几乎是其自身成功的受害者。好吧，它是另一种成功的受害者。是的，而且这种强大的新形式，我的意思是，它是用骑士和城堡进行的压迫。不仅仅是英格兰，以及后来苏格兰和爱尔兰受到它的影响，它也在意大利。所以诺曼冒险家旅行到那里，他们征服了意大利南部，他们征服了西西里岛的穆斯林国家，他们入侵了巴尔干半岛，他们，你知道，他们给了拜占庭皇帝
an incredibly bloody nose in the balkans and then they provide the cutting edge for the first crusade so these are quite simply the best warriors in europe yeah and england is one of their victims england is just most high profile victim england is the hype the most and and that's why the norman conquest is is so unusual the the fact that you know a band of men can move in and take over an entire kingdom nothing really quite like it happens apart from the normal conquest perfect point to take a break tom and we can go and sharpen our swords and build our castles and stuff um and then we'll come back and um do the questions see you in a minute. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. In podcasting terms, we've seen off the Norwegians at Stamford Bridge, and now we're marching desperately south to find the Normans have landed at Pevensey
在巴尔干半岛一个极其血腥的教训，然后他们为第一次十字军东征提供了尖端力量。所以这些简直是欧洲最好的战士。是的，英格兰是他们的受害者之一。英格兰只是最引人注目的受害者。英格兰是，最，而且这就是为什么诺曼征服是如此不寻常。事实上，你知道，一群人可以搬进来并接管整个王国，除了诺曼征服外，真的没有类似的事情发生。休息的完美时机，汤姆，我们可以去磨我们的剑，建造我们的城堡之类的东西，然后我们会回来，嗯，做问题。一会儿见。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。在播客方面，我们已经在斯坦福桥击败了挪威人，现在我们正拼命向南行军，发现诺曼人已经在佩文西登陆了
with a ton of questions, and we're going to get through them now like arrows falling onto us exactly it's from danny k uh and we've sort of addressed this a bit but he says why despite a relatively well-developed state was england such an easy target for invaders we've kind of answered that but we haven't answered his second his follow-up which is what do the normans do to change that? So why does it change? Why don't more people invade England after the Normans have landed? Why don't everybody else pile in and try to take England from them, Tom? Well, because they're a car source.
带着一堆问题，我们现在要像箭一样穿过它们，落在我们身上。完全正确，这是来自丹尼·K的问题，我们已经稍微讨论过这一点，但他问，尽管有一个相对发达的国家，为什么英格兰对入侵者来说是一个如此容易的目标？我们已经回答了那个问题，但我们还没有回答他的第二个问题，即诺曼人做了什么来改变这一点？所以为什么它会改变？为什么在诺曼人登陆后没有更多的人入侵英格兰？为什么其他人不蜂拥而至并试图从他们手中夺取英格兰，汤姆？好吧，因为他们是一个汽车来源。
So, you know, there are kind of Viking kings who do have a kind of little nibble at England after 1066. But what can they do? I mean, you know. So the normans are simply too fearsome once they've got possession you can't dislodge them well they they rush around putting castles up everywhere um and i think one of the reasons that harold godwinson when he comes south from stanford bridge rather than resting and waiting for more troops to come as he probably should have done isn't is is so desperate to march on on on william is that he's been in normandy so he sees what the normans can do with their castles and he knows that even a few very rough castles put up are almost impossible to remove so i think he's rushing down to try and stop that from happening
所以，你知道，有一些维京国王在1066年后确实对英格兰有一点点蚕食。但他们能做什么？我的意思是，你知道。所以诺曼人一旦占领了就太可怕了，你无法驱逐他们。好吧，他们到处跑着建造城堡，而且我认为哈罗德·戈德温森从斯坦福桥向南走时，而不是休息并等待更多军队到来，正如他可能应该做的那样，如此绝望地向威廉行军的原因是，他在诺曼底待过，所以他看到了诺曼人能用他们的城堡做什么，他知道即使建造几个非常粗糙的城堡也几乎是不可能移除的。所以我认为他正匆忙赶去试图阻止这种情况发生。
um and of course the moment that um that williams become king you know he's sending his his uh his liege men out they are putting up the castles and once the castles have gone up there's no one who can pull them down because the normans have the have the military technology that prevents anyone from from from competing them and i think that's true for the vikings as well so that raises an interesting question if the if the vikings had taken england if harold hardrada had taken in do you think ultimately the normans would have won anyway because they have so much technology i think at some point that technology would have crossed yeah yeah that's an interesting i mean i kind of agree i mean that's the interesting
嗯，当然，当威廉成为国王的那一刻，你知道，他派出了他的领主们，他们正在建造城堡，一旦城堡建起来，就没有人能把它们拆掉，因为诺曼人拥有防止任何人与之竞争的军事技术。而且我认为这对维京人来说也是真的。所以这提出了一个有趣的问题，如果维京人占领了英格兰，如果哈罗德·哈德拉达占领了，你认为最终诺曼人还是会赢吗？因为他们有太多的技术。我认为在某个时候，那种技术会跨越。是的，是的，这是一个有趣的，我的意思是，我有点同意。我的意思是，这是有趣的
thing is that the argument is that this is a pivotal moment because it brings england into the norman and then the french orbit but i suppose the ultimate point surely is that that england would have been claimed by that orbit at some point in the next yeah i think is anyway i i think i think within the next few decades because i i think that right that the lethal quality of of the military technology that had been developed in france and the militant quality of the papal revolution meant that England couldn't be allowed to drift along as it was. It's sort of like the same question about the English language, isn't it? It's often said this is a pivotal moment in the evolution of English,
事情是，论点是这是一个关键时刻，因为它把英格兰带入了诺曼，然后是法国的轨道。但我认为最终的观点肯定是，英格兰在未来几年内会被那个轨道所要求。是的，我想是的。我认为在未来几十年内，因为我认为，那种在法国开发的军事技术的致命质量和教皇革命的好战质量意味着英格兰不能被允许像那样漂流。这有点像关于英语的同一个问题，不是吗？人们常说这是英语演变的一个关键时刻，
that it absorbs French words and that sort of stuff. But I suppose you could argue that France's cultural gravitational pull meant that at some point in the next few hundred years English was bound to take in lots of French words because of trade because of cultural contacts yeah I think so there would have been court contacts and stuff like that okay let's have another question um I'll ask it again I guess uh Chet Archbold so Chet is a friend of the show we're very used to Chet's questions. Chet says he wants to know who was Edward's lawful heir. Can we resolve that?
它吸收了法语单词之类的东西。但我认为你可以争辩说，法国的文化引力意味着在未来几百年里的某个时候，由于贸易，由于文化接触，英语注定会吸收大量的法语单词。是的，我想是的，会有宫廷接触之类的东西。好吧，让我们再问一个问题，嗯，我再问一次，我想。切特·阿奇博尔德，所以切特是节目的朋友，我们非常习惯切特的问题。切特说他想知道谁是爱德华的合法继承人。我们能解决这个问题吗？
And, well, he's asked three questions. My gosh. Let's do the Edward's lawful heir first. Edgar Atheling, I think, was the lawful heir. But it doesn't matter, does it? Because it's irrelevant who the lawful heir was, right? At this time, ever since there's been Danish invasions, the crown has been changing hands lots.
好吧，他问了三个问题。天哪。我们先来讨论爱德华的合法继承人吧。我认为埃德加·艾瑟林是合法继承人。但这并不重要，对吧？因为谁是合法继承人根本无关紧要，对吧？从丹麦人入侵以来，王位已经多次易手了。
I mean, it's not the right question, I guess. Well, except that, no, except that, there is a kind of sacral quality to the line of Alfred, which Edgar belongs to. It's the House of Wessex. belongs it's the house of wessex and and that's that's edgar is the house of wessex guy and but he could never have got it right because he was too young but he's an athlete and everyone calls him athlete and athlete means you know deserves to be king crown prince almost yeah yes but but but with the sense
我的意思是，这可能不是正确的问题。嗯，除了……不，除了阿尔弗雷德的血统有一种神圣的特质，而埃德加正是属于这一血统。那是威塞克斯王朝，埃德加就是威塞克斯王朝的人。但他永远不可能得到王位，因为他太年轻了，但他是个“艾瑟林”（Atheling），大家都叫他“艾瑟林”，而“艾瑟林”的意思是，你知道的，理应成为国王，几乎就是王储，是的，但是……
that you have the right to become king so so why does no one speak up for him when edward the confessor you know breathes his last because he's 13 all frightened of harold gobbinson yeah because because he's 13 because they know that um that they don't want that they don't want the normans they don't they don't trust edgar to stand against the normans harold is is a general of proven ability um yeah so they're rallying to that they're rallying to the guy who who will keep england english so choosing harold is not this kind of weird illegitimate they've been intimidated by godwinson kind of mobs um it's a completely reasonable legitimate choice yes it is okay good because that's what i think um what about chet's
那种你拥有成为国王权利的感觉。那么，当忏悔者爱德华咽下最后一口气时，为什么没有人为他说话呢？因为他才13岁，而且害怕哈罗德·戈德温森。是的，因为他才13岁，因为他们知道……他们不想要诺曼人，他们不信任埃德加能对抗诺曼人。哈罗德是一位久经考验的将军，是的，所以他们团结在他周围，团结在那个能让英格兰保持英格兰特色的人周围。所以选择哈罗德并不是什么奇怪的非法行为，也不是被戈德温森的暴徒恐吓的结果，这是一个完全合理、合法的选择。是的，确实如此。好的，很好，因为我也是这么想的。那么切特（Chet）的
next question he asks about class so there is this argument that people called let's say glanville are more likely to be rich because they're descended from the normans than people called smith who are likely to be you know still kind of you know working class um sort of salt of the earth britons. Do you buy this? Do you think the Norman conquest has left a class system that has endured for a millennium?
下一个问题，他问到了阶级。有一种观点认为，像“格兰维尔”（Glanville）这样姓氏的人，因为是诺曼人的后裔，所以更有可能富有，而像“史密斯”（Smith）这样姓氏的人，可能仍然是工人阶级，也就是所谓的英国中坚力量。你相信这个说法吗？你认为诺曼征服留下了一个持续了千年的阶级制度吗？
Yes. You do? I do, yes. You do? I do. Do you not? I mean, I think statistically. There was some study
是的。你相信吗？我相信，是的。你相信吗？我相信。你不信吗？我的意思是，我认为从统计学上来说。有项研究
published a couple of years ago. Yes, there was. Exactly. That's what I'm thinking of. So I'm very happy to go along with that. The people with Norman names. Montgomery. monty was very proud of being how i'm a bit i'm a bit uh i'm a bit dubious about this to be honest with you but um i think it's definitely i mean you made the point in the first half of the show that it's definitely what it's actually
几年前发表过。是的，确实有。没错，我指的就是那个。所以我很乐意认同这一点。那些有诺曼姓氏的人。蒙哥马利（Montgomery）。蒙蒂（Monty）非常自豪自己是……老实说，我对此有点怀疑，但……我认为这绝对是……我的意思是，你在节目上半部分提到了，这绝对是……实际上
clearly made a difference to is our sense of class if not the reality then our our understanding of it so our sense of a sort of dualism between haves and have-nots between a ruling class and an oppressed mass i mean that's there before you know marx or anything like that that's there in the middle ages isn't it it's there and it's there in the middle ages um and it's it's hugely influential i mean it's kind of growing up there by the 14th 15th centuries as you say the norman yoke and it's massively or we've already talked about ivanhoe and walter scott and that idea of of there being a massive division between normans and english and i and that's not made up that's real i mean i think it is made up i think it is made up i think i think
它显然造成了差异的是我们的阶级意识，如果不是现实的话，那也是我们对它的理解。所以我们有一种关于贫富之间、统治阶级与被压迫大众之间二元对立的感觉，我的意思是，这在马克思或其他任何人出现之前就存在了，这在中世纪就存在了，不是吗？它存在，而且在中世纪就存在，而且它影响深远。我的意思是，正如你所说，到14、15世纪，这种“诺曼枷锁”的观念已经形成，我们已经谈到了《艾凡赫》和沃尔特·司各特，以及那种诺曼人和英国人之间存在巨大鸿沟的观念，我认为那不是编造的，那是真实的。我的意思是，我认为那是编造的，我认为那是编造的，我认为……
that i mean certainly by the time that john loses normandy in the in the 13th early 13th century everyone is thinking of themselves as english but for a long time tom maybe a couple of hundred years people are there is a sense of england is what one and a half million people and the normative come over and we're talking about tens of thousands maybe maybe 20 000 15 000 or something yeah they have all the land they have all the power i mean they are a ruling class right you you you get this with the um the the first english historians to write about you of Malmesbury um and uh who who talks about um new faces everywhere enjoying England's riches and gnawing at her vitals makes me sick it makes me sick to hear this stuff and and and you've got um Henry of Huntingdon who says that that God
我的意思是，肯定到了约翰王在13世纪初失去诺曼底的时候，每个人都认为自己是英国人了。但很长一段时间，汤姆，也许几百年，人们……有一种感觉，英格兰有一百五十万人，而诺曼人来了，我们说的是几万人，也许两万，一万五千人左右。是的，他们拥有所有的土地，拥有所有的权力。我的意思是，他们是一个统治阶级，对吧？你从第一批写到你的英国历史学家马姆斯伯里的威廉那里就能看到这一点，他谈到了……到处都是新面孔，享受着英格兰的财富，啃食着她的命脉，这让我作呕。听到这些东西让我作呕。而且你还有亨廷顿的亨利，他说上帝
basically has invented the Normans to wipe out the english so that's yeah so that sense is is very real but but i think it fades pretty it's gone by the 13th century i think and the normans basically now see themselves as english because i suppose they're fighting the french right so they're defining themselves against the french do you yes they are absolutely yes they are and but but what also happens is say with the peasants revolt you're getting peasants there who were mythologising the Norman conquest to explain their sufferings. What about Chet's final question,
基本上创造了诺曼人来消灭英国人，所以是的，那种感觉是非常真实的。但我认为它消失得很快，到13世纪它就消失了，我认为诺曼人基本上现在把自己看作是英国人了，因为我想他们在和法国人打仗，对吧？所以他们通过对抗法国人来定义自己。你同意吗？是的，他们绝对是，是的，他们是。但同时发生的事情是，比如在农民起义中，你看到那里的农民将诺曼征服神话化，来解释他们所受的苦难。那么切特的最后一个问题呢，
which is about would England have looked more to Scandinavia than France? I mean, I think that's the question that people often ask. If it had gone otherwise, would England effectively be part of Scandinavia? And would we be eating cinnamon buns fantastic mid-century furniture you know very we'd have very generous
关于英格兰是否会更多地看向斯堪的纳维亚而不是法国？我的意思是，我认为这是人们经常问的问题。如果情况不同，英格兰会实际上成为斯堪的纳维亚的一部分吗？我们会吃着肉桂卷，用着很棒的中世纪家具，你知道，我们会拥有非常慷慨的
pensions and pay colossal taxes if they'd won we would all be listening to Abba and shopping at Ikea oh we are yeah well you see I love this because I'm a real Scandi-i file so i kind of think oh if only hadrada had won it'd be great we'd all be watching somewhere miserable trials about detectives
养老金，如果他们赢了，还要缴纳巨额税款，我们都会听着ABBA的歌，在宜家购物。哦，我们确实是这样。好吧，你看，我喜欢这个，因为我是一个真正的斯堪的纳维亚迷，所以我有点想，哦，如果哈拉尔德（Hardrada）赢了该多好，我们都会看一些关于侦探的悲惨剧集。
there we are um no i think that for the as we've discussed i think that the gravitational pull of france would have been too great. And we can tell that because the same is true of Scandinavia. The Scandinavian kingdoms likewise start building Gothic cathedrals and going on crusade and having knights and castles and things. So it's a cultural pull that I think was not to be resisted. Okay, here's one for you on on the subject of norway this is from stefan jensen since i'm norwegian i of course have to ask how close to a great and awesome norwegian-led north sea empire was king harold really before he lost at
就是这样。嗯，不，我认为正如我们讨论过的，我认为法国的引力太大了。我们可以看出这一点，因为斯堪的纳维亚也是如此。斯堪的纳维亚王国同样开始建造哥特式大教堂，参加十字军东征，拥有骑士和城堡等等。所以我认为这是一种无法抗拒的文化引力。好吧，这里有一个关于挪威的问题，来自斯特凡·詹森（Stefan Jensen），因为我是挪威人，我当然要问，在哈拉尔德国王在黑斯廷斯战败之前，他离建立一个伟大而令人敬畏的挪威领导的北海帝国到底有多近？
hastings could he have made it e.g the timing had differed by a few weeks or was it a doom project from the beginning so well that could harold hadrada of course because the the example of canute suggests that it wasn't necessarily doomed from the beginning because canute had a north sea empire but i suppose the argument against it is that north sea empire was was liable to fragmentation so canute's empire breaks up as we know um and maybe even if hadrada had won at you know if he'd won at stanford bridge if he'd then beaten william which is according to you unlikely because of the technological gap um would england have remained as part of a north sea empire or would that empire have inherently
他能做到吗？例如，如果时间差了几个星期，还是说这从一开始就是一个注定失败的项目？嗯，哈拉尔德·哈德拉达当然可以，因为克努特大帝的例子表明，这并不一定从一开始就注定失败，因为克努特拥有一个北海帝国。但我认为反对的论点是，北海帝国容易分裂，所以克努特的帝国正如我们所知解体了。即使哈德拉达赢了，你知道，如果他在斯坦福桥赢了，如果他随后击败了威廉，而根据你的说法，由于技术差距，这不太可能……英格兰会保持作为北海帝国的一部分吗？还是那个帝国会本质上
fragmented um because it because of its sort of yeah... Yeah, I think it would have fragmented. Yeah, I mean, it's hard to imagine. Also, how old was an old guy? He's 50, isn't he? He's about 50 when he... Yeah, so it's his last... So he'll be dead in 5, 10 years, probably. And one of the things you get throughout this period, right, is a series of succession crises.
分裂？因为它的那种……是的，我认为它会分裂。我的意思是，很难想象。而且，哈拉尔德是个老家伙了，他50岁了，不是吗？他50岁左右的时候……是的，所以这是他的最后一次……所以他可能在5到10年内就会死。而且你在这一时期一直看到的事情之一，对吧，就是一系列的继承危机。
So that's why the crown is swapping so much, and it's such a confusing story in the sort of hundred years before 1066. So there'd been another succession crisis. Well, I guess. Of how Drada died. And what would have happened then? Tostig, I guess. Yeah, well, there would have been some other earl would have challenged him.
所以这就是为什么王位换手如此频繁，在1066年之前的百年里，这是一个如此令人困惑的故事。所以还会发生另一次继承危机。好吧，我想是这样。哈拉尔德·哈德拉达死了。那之后会发生什么？托斯蒂格（Tostig），我想。是的，好吧，会有其他伯爵挑战他。
And it would have been somebody would have pitched up from Norway. And it would have all been a bit of a mess. Tostig. And then the Normans would have come over at some point, wouldn't they? And then, you know, the normans would have come over at some point wouldn't they and then you know the go i mean but but clearly tostig is thinking i'm going to get the throne when harold when harold dies i always had a soft spot for tostig um our cat yes our cat is named after him so we had it we had um we had harold uh tostig and edith um harold harold harold wandered off uh but we still got tostig and edith um harold harold harold wandered off uh but we still got tostig and edith
而且会有人从挪威冒出来。那一切都会变得一团糟。托斯蒂格。然后诺曼人会在某个时候过来，不是吗？然后，你知道，诺曼人会在某个时候过来，不是吗？然后，你知道，我的意思是……但显然托斯蒂格在想，当哈拉尔德死的时候，我要得到王位。我一直对托斯蒂格情有独钟，我们的猫，是的，我们的猫就是以他的名字命名的。所以我们有哈拉尔德、托斯蒂格和伊迪丝。哈拉尔德走开了，但我们还有托斯蒂格和伊迪丝。
so how do we have to swear an oath to some other yes he did he did he wandered off south and home yeah he did he's with some other home oh that's sad watchful mockery what a traumatic moment it is but we still have tostig um okay here's another one we've got another yeah another one for you um um patrick 851 was william's real triumph ending the viking way of war in favor of cavalry if so were the english exiles why why were the english exiles so successful in the mediterranean after they fled e.g the english guard in byzantium yeah so the english guard in byzantium you'll know more about this than me tom so they're basically the Varangian Guard have been there for a while they're the emperor's kind of bodyguard and they're recruited from Norsemen they've often come down from sort of Kiev and Rus and all that sort
所以我们为什么要向其他人宣誓效忠？是的，他确实走开了，他向南走，回家了。是的，他确实走了，他和别人在一起。哦，那太悲伤了。警惕的嘲弄，多么痛苦的时刻。但我们还有托斯蒂格。好吧，这里还有另一个问题，我们还有另一个，是的，另一个给你的。帕特里克851问，威廉真正的胜利是终结了维京人的战争方式，转而支持骑兵吗？如果是这样，为什么英国流亡者在逃亡后在地中海如此成功？例如拜占庭的英格兰卫队。是的，所以拜占庭的英格兰卫队，汤姆，你比我更了解这一点。所以他们基本上是瓦兰吉卫队（Varangian Guard），已经在那里待了一段时间了，他们是皇帝的保镖，是从诺斯人中招募的，他们通常是从基辅和罗斯等地南下的，
of stuff the sort of trade routes that the Norse have established going down into what's now Ukraine but the Varangian Guard pick up a lot of Anglo-Saxon exiles, don't they? Am I right? Yeah, that's right. And they're sort of feared because of their strange moustaches and sort of hard drinking ways. They're basically football hooligans who've gone to Turkey, modern day, what's now Turkey, and sort of behaving badly and being fearsome and stuff. Well, the Warrington Guard go with the Byzantines to confront the Normans in the Balkans after 1066 and end up in a barn and the Normans burn them to death. So it's not as successful as all that. They're not, unfortunately. But having said that, I think the, you know, the housecarls, the personal guard around the English king are simply the best infantry in Europe so what you have at Hastings this is they've got the shield wall tactics haven't they and all that stuff
那种诺斯人建立的通往现在乌克兰的贸易路线。但瓦兰吉卫队吸收了很多盎格鲁-撒克逊流亡者，对吧？我说的对吗？是的，没错。他们因为奇怪的胡子和酗酒的方式而令人恐惧。他们基本上是去了现代土耳其的足球流氓，表现得很糟糕，而且很可怕。好吧，瓦兰吉卫队在1066年后随拜占庭人去巴尔干半岛对抗诺曼人，结果被困在谷仓里，诺曼人把他们烧死了。所以并没有那么成功。不幸的是，他们没有。但话虽如此，我认为，你知道，皇家卫队（housecarls），即英国国王身边的私人卫队，简直是欧洲最好的步兵。所以你在黑斯廷斯看到的是，他们有盾墙战术，对吧，还有所有那些东西。
this this is um you know this is uh kind of European cup that they're they're going for it's the best cavalry against the best infantry and one of the things that's that's really unusual about Hastings is that it goes on all day. I mean, that's really unusual for an ancient battle or a medieval battle. They're usually over in about an hour. And it lasts all day. It's how exhausting. They must have been absolutely, I mean, barely able to lift their weapons at the end, you would assume.
这是……你知道，这是某种欧洲杯，他们全力以赴。这是最好的骑兵对抗最好的步兵。黑斯廷斯战役中非常不寻常的一点是，它持续了一整天。我的意思是，这对于古代战役或中世纪战役来说非常不寻常。它们通常在一个小时内就结束了。而它持续了一整天。多么令人筋疲力尽。你认为到最后他们肯定几乎连武器都举不起来了。
A lot of them presumably just die because they're too tired to fight anymore. Yeah, I think so and also what's impressive is that um both the normans and the english at one point look as if they're going to break so there's the rumor that not that william's been killed and that they will and then william takes his helmet off and rallies them and then um the uh anglo-saxons have run down the hill um lots of them get killed but they still don't break and even when even when the shield wall breaks they remain on the top and that's that's essentially what that's that's why the battle is so decisive is that harold doesn't flee he stays where he is but tom the accounts of the battle um i mean how much is that actually what happened and how much
他们中的许多人大概只是因为太累而无法再战而死。是的，我想是这样。而且令人印象深刻的是，诺曼人和英国人在某个时刻看起来都要崩溃了。所以有传言说威廉被杀了，然后威廉摘下头盔振作士气，然后盎格鲁-撒克逊人冲下山，许多人被杀，但他们仍然没有崩溃。即使当盾墙崩溃时，他们仍然留在山顶。这就是为什么这场战役如此具有决定性，因为哈罗德没有逃跑，他留在了原地。但汤姆，关于这场战役的记载，我的意思是，那到底有多少是真实发生的，有多少
of that is just sort of standard battle narrative the formulae i mean people are always almost being killed in battles and lifting their helmets and saying i'm still alive and and sort of staging feints and being chased and then coming back and isn't that well the sources the sources the sources for a medieval relative to a needle battle are pretty good for hastings you know they're written by people who were there or who witnessed it who talked to eyewitnesses. And you've got the Bayeux Tapestry. So obviously there are details that we don't know. It's mythologized.
只是标准的战役叙事公式？我的意思是，人们在战役中总是差点被杀，然后摘下头盔说“我还活着”，或者进行佯攻，被追赶，然后又回来。难道不是吗？好吧，来源，来源，对于中世纪战役来说，黑斯廷斯的来源相当不错，你知道，它们是由在场的人或目击者写的，他们与目击者交谈过。而且你有贝叶挂毯。所以显然有一些我们不知道的细节。它被神话化了。
People can't know for sure. But I think the basic outline and the thing about the Normans and then the English kind of breaking is repeated in different ways in near contemporary sources. So they are not copying one another they're clearly drawing on a sense that this had actually happened so i'm i'm i'm happy with that i think it happened but to just go back to the question for a second about the varangian guard and the english guard in byzantium i think that's one of the most romantic stories in all history actually i love the Varangian guard sort of stuff. So you've probably seen, I can't remember if we've talked about this in a previous podcast,
人们无法确定。但我认为基本轮廓，以及关于诺曼人和英国人崩溃的事情，在近现代的来源中以不同的方式重复出现。所以他们不是在互相抄袭，他们显然是从这确实发生过的感觉中汲取的。所以我很高兴，我认为它发生了。但回到关于瓦兰吉卫队和拜占庭英格兰卫队的问题，我认为那实际上是历史上最浪漫的故事之一。我喜欢瓦兰吉卫队之类的东西。所以你可能见过，我不记得我们是否在之前的播客中谈过这个，
the graffiti in Hagia Sophia. By Halfdan, I think. Isn't he called Halfdan? He's a sentry or something and he scribbles on a pillar. I can't remember how he does it. He's etched it into the wall or something. We really need to do a podcast on the Vikings in the East. It would be great.
圣索菲亚大教堂里的涂鸦。我想是哈夫丹（Halfdan）写的。他不叫哈夫丹吗？他是个哨兵之类的，他在柱子上乱涂乱画。我不记得他是怎么做的了。他把它刻在墙上之类的。我们真的需要做一个关于东方维京人的播客。那会很棒。
Well, we talked in a previous episode about Rosemary Sutcliffe's book Blood Feud, which is about an English boy who becomes a Varangian guard. And he becomes a Viking and he goes down the river and he goes to Kiev and then he ends up working for the emperor. It's great stuff. We should do a podcast just about that book anyway let's do another um question okay rob scott pick one yeah rob scott um is there any truth in the rumor that king harold was shot in the balls rather than the eyeball and that's that's quite absent isn't it because
好吧，我们在之前的一集中谈到了罗斯玛丽·萨特克利夫（Rosemary Sutcliffe）的书《血仇》（Blood Feud），讲的是一个成为瓦兰吉卫队的英国男孩。他成为了维京人，顺流而下去了基辅，最后为皇帝工作。那是很棒的内容。无论如何，我们应该做一个关于那本书的播客。让我们做另一个问题。好的，罗伯·斯科特（Rob Scott），选一个。是的，罗伯·斯科特。关于哈罗德国王是被射中睾丸而不是眼球的传言有真实性吗？这很荒谬，不是吗？因为
we're about to do one on eunuchs so yes and there's our next podcast so dominic what's your take on the was king harold shot in the eye mystery you project onto this what you want really but i think it's endured for so long partly because of that that image in the tapestry so the as far as i can understand some scholars now think that the image in the tapestry so shows two stages of his death so he's shot in the eye then he falls then he's yeah then he's butchered. Or that he's holding a spear. That the guy with the arrow is holding a spear.
我们正要做一个关于太监的节目，所以是的，那是我们的下一个播客。多米尼克，你对哈罗德国王被射中眼睛的谜团有什么看法？你真的把你想的东西投射到上面了，但我认为它之所以能流传这么久，部分是因为挂毯上的那个形象。据我所知，一些学者现在认为挂毯上的形象显示了他死亡的两个阶段：他先是被射中眼睛，然后倒下，然后被屠杀。或者他拿着长矛。那个拿箭的人拿着长矛。
Yeah. I mean, I think that Harold's shot in the eye is such a great story. And it's endured because it's... I mean, it's a better story, isn't it, than he's just butchered on the ground. And because the shot in the eye introduces the element of contingency. So it makes it easier to see him as a romantic hero if only he the arrow hadn't hit him right in the eye but maybe he could have prevailed and but the other way of saying like about it is that it's not contingency that it's the judgment of god well i knew this was coming because because
是的。我的意思是，我认为哈罗德被射中眼睛是一个很棒的故事。它之所以流传下来，是因为……我的意思是，这比他只是在地上被屠杀要好，不是吗？而且因为射中眼睛引入了偶然性的因素。所以如果箭没有正好射中他的眼睛，也许他就能获胜，这让他更容易被视为浪漫英雄。但另一种说法是，这不是偶然性，而是上帝的审判。好吧，我知道这要来了，因为
actually the the earliest extant source says that um and this is where the testicle thing comes in, as it were, is that William sees Harold on the battlefield. And William gathers some men around him and they go and attack Harold and they butcher him and they dismember him and they hack off his testicles and they behead him right nice and nice i think that that what's interesting about that is that it that is not a tradition that gets picked up um and i think one of the reasons it doesn't get picked up is that it makes william look bad whereas william has cast hastings as being you know we're putting this before god god will judge and if the battle is finished you know the story that harold gets shot in the eyes are quite early um if that happens then uh obviously it proves that god is on on william's side so i i think that question i mean it's a really interesting one gets caught up in the snarl of norman propaganda and justification they might have
实际上，现存最早的来源说……这就是睾丸的事情进来的地方，威廉在战场上看到了哈罗德。威廉召集了一些人，他们去攻击哈罗德，屠杀了他，肢解了他，砍掉了他的睾丸，并斩首了他。这很……很……我认为有趣的是，这并不是一个被采纳的传统。我认为没有被采纳的原因之一是它让威廉看起来很糟糕，而威廉将黑斯廷斯描述为“我们把这交给上帝，上帝会审判”。如果战役结束了，你知道，哈罗德被射中眼睛的故事很早就出现了，如果发生了这种情况，那么显然证明上帝站在威廉一边。所以我认为那个问题，我的意思是，这是一个非常有趣的问题，陷入了诺曼宣传和辩护的纠缠中。他们可能
wanted to think that and on the on the topic of of romance and har. They might have wanted to think that. And on the topic of romance and Harold, one from Pink Haze, is King Harold really buried at Waltham Abbey? I've been to both Battle and at Waltham Abbey and have seen what they assume is his grave, but is it him? So the story of what happens to Harold is terribly romantic.
想那样想。关于浪漫和哈罗德的话题，来自Pink Haze的一个问题：哈罗德国王真的埋在沃尔瑟姆修道院吗？我去过黑斯廷斯和沃尔瑟姆修道院，看过他们认为是他的坟墓的东西，但那是他吗？所以关于哈罗德遭遇的故事非常浪漫。
Which I don't know. Isn't there a claim that he's also at Bosham? Yeah, that's right. And there has been an argument about, permission was refused, I think, to dig up a grave in Bosham to do DNA testing or something. I mean, what do you think, Tom? Do you have a definitive answer?
我不知道。有没有一种说法说他也在博萨姆（Bosham）？是的，没错。关于挖掘博萨姆的一个坟墓进行DNA测试之类的许可被拒绝了，我想是这样。我的意思是，你怎么看，汤姆？你有明确的答案吗？
I don't know. How can you? I don't know. But the story, well, so again, the earliest thing is that William refuses to give the body of harold to um to harold's mother that's right give it to another norman yeah they make it they make a joke that um harold's body should be put um on the foreshore looking out to sea and that that's kind of interesting because bosom is on the sea it's on the sussex coast so maybe that's um but that there are a lot of medieval stories that he he survives the battle and becomes a hermit i like that so i like that one so he'll
我不知道。你怎么能知道？我不知道。但故事……好吧，同样，最早的事情是威廉拒绝把哈罗德的尸体交给哈罗德的母亲。没错，交给另一个诺曼人。是的，他们开了一个玩笑，说哈罗德的尸体应该放在前滩，面朝大海。这很有趣，因为博萨姆在海上，在苏塞克斯海岸，所以也许那是……但有很多中世纪的故事说他在战役中幸存下来，成为了一名隐士。我喜欢那个，所以我喜欢那个。所以他
maybe he'll come here we've been told by the producer that we can only do one more question so i think we should do two more questions just assert just just to assert some pathetic some pathetic sort of vestige of power over our own podcast so i think we should do conor moon's question because it's very crucial if you can be very crucial um how if all if at all just says conor moon did life change for the submerged nine-tenths of the population when norman rule was established you know was it life as usual for the peasants or were there big changes and i guess that's a really huge question isn't it so for you're living in a village somewhere in lincolnshire or or herefordshire how much does this actually matter to you is that the replacement of one elite by another you know does it make a big difference in your in your
也许他会来这里。制片人告诉我们只能再问一个问题，所以我认为我们应该再问两个问题，只是为了坚持……为了在我们自己的播客上坚持某种可怜的权力残余。所以我认为我们应该做康纳·穆恩（Conor Moon）的问题，因为它非常关键。如果可以的话，非常关键……康纳·穆恩问，当诺曼统治建立时，对于那九分之八的底层人口来说，生活发生了什么变化？你知道，对于农民来说，生活照旧，还是发生了巨大的变化？我想这是一个非常巨大的问题，不是吗？所以，你住在林肯郡或赫里福德郡的某个村庄，这对你来说真的重要吗？那是用一个精英取代另一个精英，你知道，这在你的生活中会有很大的不同吗？
life tom well i'll tell you who it does make a big difference for is the slaves because about a tenth of the population in ang-Saxon England are enslaved. And the Norman Conquest effectively ends that. And there is evidence that William is ideologically opposed to slavery, that he regards it as being contrary to God's will. So you could cast the Norman invasion as an anti-slavery movement as well. Well, you could. To throw into the mix okay and so on that topic of what gets lost with the norman conquest here is one from tim vasby
汤姆，好吧，我告诉你这对谁有很大的不同，那就是奴隶，因为盎格鲁-撒克逊英格兰大约十分之一的人口是奴隶。而诺曼征服实际上结束了这一点。有证据表明威廉在意识形态上反对奴隶制，他认为这违背了上帝的意愿。所以你也可以把诺曼入侵看作是一场反奴隶制运动。好吧，你可以。把它加入其中。好的，关于诺曼征服失去了什么的话题，这里有一个来自蒂姆·瓦斯比·伯尼（Tim Vasby Bernie）的问题，
bernie friend of the show um when you think of 1066 various aspects of anglo-saxon culture came to an end so we've talked about slavery that's one aspect that comes to an end yeah which of these are we most saddened by so dominic you're a romantic on this i am so you see i what i mourn tom is something that probably is utterly made up which is the sort of the traditional liberties of the anglo-saxon you know the anglo the ordinary the ordinary the middle england you know crushed by these frenchified um and i'm sure that's utterly invented but i kind of like the romance of the of the norman yoke and i suppose there's um ah you know the sources suggest that actually norman rule wasn't a bundle of laughs i mean people sort of english sources say you know
节目的朋友。当你想到1066年时，盎格鲁-撒克逊文化的各个方面都结束了。所以我们谈到了奴隶制，那是结束的一个方面。是的，我们对其中哪一个最感到悲伤？所以多米尼克，你在这方面是个浪漫主义者。我是。所以我哀悼的是汤姆，可能是完全编造的东西，那就是盎格鲁-撒克逊人的传统自由，你知道，普通人，你知道，被这些法国化的东西压垮了。我肯定那是完全编造的，但我喜欢诺曼枷锁的浪漫。我想……你知道，来源表明诺曼统治实际上并不是那么有趣。我的意思是，人们，英国的来源说，你知道，
they they sort of wept and cried out and to God such was the oppression. So I think there is obviously a sense of some degree of liberty or self-government or cultural integrity being lost, I guess. The other thing that's lost, of course, is the hair. Yeah, so there's a sort of hairiness to the Anglo-Saxons, isn't there, in the Bayeux Tapestry, don't they have moustaches and stuff? Yeah. So they look like the village people or something. And that's obviously
他们哭泣并向上帝呼喊，因为压迫太严重了。所以我认为显然有一种失去某种程度的自由、自治或文化完整性的感觉。当然，失去的另一件事是头发。是的，所以盎格鲁-撒克逊人有一种多毛感，不是吗？在贝叶挂毯上，他们不是有胡子之类的吗？是的。所以他们看起来像乡村合唱团（Village People）之类的。这显然
been lost to some extent, hasn't it? I mean, as a clean-shaven person myself, I suppose I should applaud the Norman. Are you never tempted by a kind of Godwinson moustache? I think I'd look ridiculous. I think you should try it. I mean, more ridiculous than I do now. You think so? Yeah, I think you should try it. Maybe. Alright, what do you think's
在某种程度上已经失去了，不是吗？我的意思是，作为一个刮得干干净净的人，我想我应该为诺曼人鼓掌。你从来没有被戈德温森式的胡子诱惑过吗？我想我会看起来很荒谬。我认为你应该试试。我的意思是，比我现在看起来更荒谬。你这么认为吗？是的，我认为你应该试试。也许吧。好吧，你认为什么
been... I mean, you're another Norman tonsured man. For me, I to do now yeah i think you should try it maybe all right what do you think's been what do you i mean you're another norman norman for me i'm i i i think what gets broken is the distinctive quality of the english church uh and our sense of the saints the anglo-saxon saints which um as you'll know from we did the saint cuthbertbert. St. Cuthbert does get appropriated. Quite a lot of them get appropriated. But because essentially the Normans move in and they take over all the cathedrals, the monasteries and everything, that sense of a kind of organic link with the pre-conquest church
被……我的意思是，你是另一个诺曼式剃头的人。对我来说，我……我认为被破坏的是英国教会的独特品质，以及我们对圣徒的感觉，盎格鲁-撒克逊圣徒，正如你从我们做的圣卡斯伯特（Saint Cuthbert）节目中知道的那样。圣卡斯伯特确实被挪用了。相当多的人被挪用了。但因为诺曼人基本上搬进来，接管了所有的大教堂、修道院和一切，那种与征服前教会的有机联系感
and its traditions and its saints, that gets broken. And I'm sad about that. Although possibly not as sad about the fact that you don't have a moustache and i really think that you seriously think about firming your rights as a free-born anglo-saxon by growing one tom like one last question which has occurred to me from what you you just said do you think that the the fact that such a question is being asked by the reverend tim vasby bernie and the sense of 2066 is a rupture and a lost sense of liberty do you think that plays a part in English exceptionalism England's sense of itself is distinct I think that um I think it's
及其传统和圣徒，被破坏了。我对此感到难过。虽然可能不像你没有胡子那样难过，我真的认为你应该认真考虑通过留胡子来巩固你作为自由出生的盎格鲁-撒克逊人的权利，汤姆。最后一个问题，从你刚才说的话中我想到的，你认为蒂姆·瓦斯比·伯尼牧师提出的这样一个问题，以及1066年是一个断裂和失去自由感的意义，你认为这在英国例外论中起作用吗？英格兰对自身作为独特的看法。我认为……我认为这是
very very when we talked about this right at the beginning about it the role that 1066 plays in the secondary school curriculum that it's right at the beginning um yeah I think that if England's exceptional it's exceptional in the way that it describes as its national myth, the story of which the English get defeated. I mean, yeah, it's that's not something that the Scots or the Americans do. It seems very, very odd. And I think that that does kind of I think it's always slightly served to qualify the English triumphalism, certainly. And perhaps... I think it reflects our enormous sense of self-confidence.
非常非常……当我们谈到这一点时，就在开头，关于1066年在中学课程中扮演的角色，它就在开头。是的，我认为如果英格兰是例外的，它是以它所描述的民族神话的方式例外的，即英国人被击败的故事。我的意思是，是的，这不是苏格兰人或美国人会做的事情。这看起来非常非常奇怪。而且我认为这确实在某种程度上一直稍微起到限制英国胜利主义的作用，当然。也许……我认为这反映了我们巨大的自信心。
Possibly. You have to be a really top nation to start with. To celebrate a defeat. Yes, maybe. Well, on that patriotic note, I think we probably better celebrate the end of 1066. We have another episode coming up, don't we, on Wednesday, a live episode.
可能吧。你必须是一个非常顶级的国家才能开始。庆祝一场失败。是的，也许吧。好吧，带着那个爱国主义的音符，我想我们最好还是庆祝1066年的结束。我们还有另一集，不是吗，在周三，一集直播。
Assassinations. So the link, by the time this goes out, may well already be up. If not, it will be going up imminently. And yes, it's on assassinations. And then on thursday we have an episode in which we go through our list of top 10 eunuchs and i think we're not giving a spoiler are we harold isn't one of them so no he's not we've got some very good eunuchs though
暗杀。所以链接，到这集播出时，可能已经发布了。如果没有，它很快就会发布。是的，是关于暗杀的。然后在周四，我们有一集，我们将浏览我们的十大太监名单，我想我们不会剧透，对吧？哈罗德不是其中之一，所以不，他不是。不过我们有一些非常好的太监。
yeah we've got very good eunuchs good eunuchs we've got them so um we will see you hopefully on wednesday and hopefully on Thursday. Thanks very much. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的，我们有非常好的太监，好的太监，我们有他们。所以，我们希望在周三和周四见到你们。非常感谢。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。如需奖励剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在restishistorypod.com注册。那是restishistorypod.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。